you gotta swear not to tell anyone tell
anyone what
[Music]
i want to be a drag queen oh my dear
this is a story of a
an older man
who was fabulous back in the day but
feels like he's lost it and this young
young man comes into his shop and wakes
him up and brings him back to life again
and it's a two there's something two way
about it and what was also beautiful to
observe is there was a two-way
relationship between richard and max as
a very experienced actor and a very an
actor coming at it for the first time
you know and just how richard looked
after max in those in those scenes was
just so beautiful to observe he wasn't
so not patronizing he so didn't come as
the the big grand actor telling the
young actor this is how you do it he
just watched observe and that show
remember saying richard saying i'm
learning as much from max as probably
he's learning from me
it was just amazing to watch
you just found yourself
a mentor yeah yes please it is torture
to wear heels and it is very tight to
wear spanx and it is very uncomfortable
where 36 double d cup brassiere that
amount of makeup
my hat goes off to any woman that puts
on even a quarter of that stuff the fact
that my wife can get ready in 10 minutes
and look fabulous it took them two and a
half hours like i was like an old
ferrari at the pit stop in monte carlo
all these people coming in change the
wheels change the tires
and then off you go it's
unbelievable i owe that team everything
not nervous terrified because i've never
done that before and i had to do a
sheffield accent so all of those things
and i thought well at my age for these
things to come my way and
to have that amount of terror is a good
thing i heard
so why do you want to be a drag queen
because it's all i ever dream of
and when i close my eyes it's all i can
see
more than anything and especially this
historical moment in time where we've
had four years of you know divide and
rule and such
hatred expressed between people in the
same country
and brexit that we're having to deal
with here in the fall fallout of that in
in england
a movie that's an authentic true story
that is about inclusivity diversity and
above all tolerance i think that is
you can never have enough of that and so
who you want to love how you want to
dress how you want to live who you want
to believe in who you want to kiss
i'm i'm awful everybody should be
allowed to do whatever they want to do
you know i i actually
really related to the aspect of jamie
because you know i had i was lucky i had
incredibly supportive parents with me i
wasn't out when i was at school but i
was you know often called all those
names under the sun you get called at
school and i i gave it back as good as i
got i wasn't i was i didn't let myself
be a victim and i think often or not um
you do see you do see queer people you
know
made the victim in the show or you know
the comic relief so it was really nice
to you know tap into something that felt
you know
more
closer to my experience
[Music]